have you guys ever had to tell a friend  that they're shooting too high how'd  that go for you  she knew oh she knew she knew and uh  yeah so she was just quiet did she  adjust  oh yeah I think she did yeah she ended  up because I think she was forced to  like like that that woman yeah  she wants a real actual man that doesn't  sound so stupid that we're saying this  but to the point when she's not getting  that actual connection with an actual  human being because she's always  fantasizing  um I think she'll be forced to Humble  herself and that's the thing when she's  forced to Humble herself and lower her  standards it'll be too late for her and  she's just gonna whatever she can get  basically well she